brought to you by sheath underwear
summer's coming and that means sweaty
dick season Sam might be wearing them
right now look at that what's the better
well promo than that if you're tired of
your dick and stuck to your balls and
your balls getting stuck to your leg
it's sheath underwear two pouches one
for your dong one for your sack nothing
sticks together so you stay cool and
comfortable all summer long oh I didn't
have to look and I'm wearing it too I
want one for your one for your sack and
one for your mistress yeah sheet was
created by US Army soldier Robert Patton
not only did he make an awesome product
but you can support a veteran-owned
company and a podcast at the same time
for our ladies in the audience check out
sheath sports bras bikini briefs and
boys shorts they have tons of cool
patterns yeah Dylan Mulvaney sporting
them it's great
so you can have tons of cool patterns
and ready for any occasion go to
sheathunderwear.com and use promo code
drunk to get 20 off your first order
that's sheets 100 money back guarantee
she's underwear.com promo drunk
sheathunderwear.com code drunk for 20
off your first order go to sheath
underwear and let them support your
balls the best the best
we might be drunk family we're having
some issues getting Bodega cat whiskey
available here in New York we need some
distribution help if you know anyone
that could help try K Hart at
houstonwhiskeysocial.com or we might be
drunk pod pod gmail.com email either
those if you have any hookups to New
York distribution we're having a real
pain in the ass here and so many people
want to sell this [__] yes we're drunk
right now it's a great ride people want
it we're trying to get into the bars
here the comedy clubs you name it let's
make some money call us some money email
us figure it out help us out Bodega cat
whiskey let's make this happen
everyone's loving it yeah and now enjoy
a great episode with uh Bobby Lee cheers
[Music]
here we are happy Fourth of July
America's holiday
the most American we know the uh the
kooky Korean Bobby Lee I'm a cookster
dude we have a special treat for oh do
it we're gonna pull that out immediately
huh yeah all right here it comes what do
we have here in Korean hot though whoa
did you replace the K with the G you
wanted to say G but you put K in there
I'm not Korean hot dogs just kill us
well this is a good combo of America but
also our lovely guest oh it looks like
your dick look it's all bloody and warts
wow what's the you know I don't eat
Korean hot dogs I like Chicago dogs but
I'll try it what's the red stuff
Ah that's ketchup the blood of the
southerners you guys you guys this looks
disgusting yeah
Kim jong-oo
can I I want to eat it later
I would rather eat a hot dog yeah I
don't know what that is this is
disgusting what is this this fried huh
yeah looks fried and there's probably a
wiener in there and it's I think
potatoes
yeah there you go what do you think
is it good no huh yeah yeah it doesn't
look like 48 on ubereats that's fun for
the first guy terrible yo so um you guys
I want to say something uh oh what no so
I showed you my I showed you my penis
yeah we have that and I have little
bumps on it but they're they're not
anything they're not STDs or anything
they look like razor bumps to me I do
shave my I do shave my [__] yeah you're
fine you're fine with a razor yeah I do
a razor yeah what yeah yeah you don't go
electric no I do razor old school damn
yeah oh my God I like I like that I like
the cuts these are samurai sword
you know what I mean like it went
through a war or kind of a Vibe yeah
yeah yeah well because otherwise they
get all long and curly and weird yeah
you see how pretty anti-semitic do you
see how purple my penis is too do you
like it the color is purple it looks
like it's like suffocating yeah like
Barney's like but you got a little uh
[__] out there that plays the violin
and uh Dory yeah who's that guy Dory is
my old roommate and he's a big fan of
her so when I told him you're coming on
he said can I come I know I said come by
I know he goes I play uh violin
Big Bang of yours by the way he's from
San Francisco
and then he starts going like you know I
mean um you know I'm not going he says
North Korean are you North Korean what
what
oh he's cute and fresh look at him yeah
you are cute yeah you're so cute dude
Dory the Explorer yeah and he's playing
Bluegrass violin now that's what you
said wow
nerd alert nerd alert
Dory a virgin I want to get a couple
things off my chest real quick number
one I did text you Sam ouch and you
didn't get me the things that's fine
what'd you ask for I asked for Red Bull
and then um two um
there's two things about New York I just
I just don't fit in in the city but I'm
gonna tell you number one I bought socks
earlier today and then look look these
are the kind of socks oh you got the toe
dip yeah like I'm a casual ninja
please because that's how [__] up your
city is that's weird I've never seen
that yeah well why would you buy socks
off a guy on the sidewalk I went to a
fancy store this is fifty dollars what
yeah and I didn't even look at the toe
thing I just bought it and I was like
and I put it on and this is what the
[__] happened oh that's crazy yeah
what store is this it was like some
Japanese store oh that's a new stock
thank you I
like that I love you and the second
thing is is that when I walk down the
street you know because um I have a
viral thing that about me being molested
by a guy with Down Syndrome oh yeah but
normally people go um like if I'm
anywhere else they go yeah oh you do
that [__] pocket talk about the down
Center but here in New York they go down
syndrome and they just point at me and
other people look at me like I have Down
syndrome that I have to do this weird
Downy wave and it's [__] weird so I
don't have Down syndrome people in New
York okay uh okay okay well you know the
Korean with the down again
[Music]
it's hard it can blend together yeah
that's all I'm saying yeah anyway a nice
little Asian fusion we call it yeah
there you go I mean Shane Gillis is
Downey exactly whites can do it too oh
for sure why you can have a Downy you
have a Downy Vibe what do you think
about these Asians who do the surgery to
look less Asian my mom got it done no
really
yeah yeah and you write soccer pool
right and my mom looks like a shocked
Mexican now
she's like what she looks like ice
walked in yeah
oh no I'll never get it done but the
other the Asian eye is a is a thing of
beauty I mean whatever you
try to keep it clean the Asian eyes you
know that's your signature yeah it's my
signature and also I just I just like it
yeah yeah I don't see as much as you
true like I can see this right here I
can't see them wow that's what we got
you look look I can't see in the jungle
yeah but everything's like you know me
in like letterbox like a movie
right that's it's so cool dude it's not
like your TV box it's a little mine's
like a Criterion Collection movie yeah
that's a little mango Lassie right there
yes and then for years we got the uh
bloody bubbly Moda over here oh yeah
what it's a Soju bloody Mary with kimchi
eat up Soju how do you like it
[Laughter]
it's like the sitcom I'm gonna have to
go
dude that thing's like mango came in my
mouth
I think about mango had a dick that
looks better than what we got that looks
[__] oh no this is good
kimchi I just I don't want Bobby's
drinking just like
[__] tomato juice and kimchi yeah
you're right that's nice that was good I
got more of that'll be the second round
no problem all right put some Red Bull
in it he's dying for a Red Bull you
drink Red Bull you got sugar-free my
wife
what's up are you on the Celsius kick
everyone's doing that now what's Celsius
you don't know itself it's like the new
it's like the new energy drink that
people think is like healthy and good
food metabolism but hmm is it is it not
booze no it's an energy drink oh okay I
don't know so could I just bring
something up I've never mentioned in
front of you and I want to make it
uncomfortable because I love you so much
oh I love you inside my house I love it
yeah yeah I love you too man sure yeah
you've never [__] me over I [__] you
over what time what did I do oh [__]
a photo
wow oh boy this is fun well you didn't
really do much
and that's the problem
so so
do you know who this guy is yes yeah
right nice guys so one time before I met
you uh-huh you're younger and we're at
the Improv yeah and I was supposed to go
next and you went into this guy because
he was the promoter of the show oh and
you said to him no I'm gonna go up
before Bobby and I remember getting one
whoa who is this guy bumping on like
I've never heard of this [__] jackass
there's a legend in L.A and then Jeffrey
was like this guy was like no he's
allowed
yeah but now we're good I don't know
what it was I think I think what
happened was I had already gotten bumped
by like three people so you do remember
that night that makes I remember yeah
was Leno there that night yeah Lena was
there that Lena was there I got bumped
by like three people and I was like I'm
[__] leaving if I'm not I I I already
have issues with LA right and I'm sorry
the one time La in La guy showed me any
[__] respect that hurt you Bobby
[Laughter]
Mark and I get zero respect in L.A zero
you know what's so funny you say that
too yeah because you're wrong
in your head I'm gonna tell you
something right now okay I can't get a
spot at the store that's ridiculous but
it's true it's not true it is true I'll
take I'll tell you why it's not true I
had a meeting with Emily yeah right and
I said I go listen the New York Comics
because when me and a bunch of La Comics
come to New York the seller opens their
door up and gives us spots and yeah
and I go I want the same thing for the
New York Comics she goes they can call
me any Sunday and I'll give them spots
oh really yeah and you guys don't do it
because you now you're like oh we have
an audience because they've never seen
you can't just show up I dude I have to
[__] I'm sorry
I I gotta let it out buddy let it go too
hot unless it's not myself you showed us
your penis within 30 seconds
yeah so what I'm saying to you is this
okay is is that you can't just show up
and go I want to go up right now we're
not doing that if you could come in if
you we know you're coming through right
on a Sunday like everyone else and you
call and go I'm available these nights
they will give you spots okay that's all
I'm saying all right well who do I mean
I go through my agent just because
you're getting rejected just text me
okay I will text Emily and I will do it
for you well it seems pretty complicated
it's not complicated no we're making it
complicated okay because the thing is um
your your butts hurt and I get it wow no
I get it Sam because you deserve it you
deserve any spot that you get but you
know there's a there was a system in La
that was set a long time ago sure right
and you know things you know
institutions it takes a while for them
to change sure okay Catholic Church
Jesus Christ
look these things don't happen overnight
I'm sorry we'll just move the priest to
another Parish but they you know know
we're gonna you know whatever you need
we'll make it happen all right we're the
best you vote and I remember met at
night and I apologize I remember because
Leno went on then Eliza went on and I
had like an 810 spot and it turned in
like a nine something yeah and I was
like guys come on okay so that I think
that's what it was that's what it was I
wasn't sorry what year was this it was a
while ago you're really holding on to
this huh well I remember because I get
pumped all the time yeah yeah oh yeah
like Chris Rockwell bought me Chappelle
right yeah sure you have the power now
there are people
that started before me or after me that
can bump me now too because they brought
risen like an Ali Wong can bump me now
which is fine right but when Sam Muriel
does it
be happy before anyone knew who the [__]
Sam Morel was
sure but you know I love you too yeah
you know and everything's fine did you
show your dick before him on the stage
and you ruined his whole clothes enough
bumps for the one evening here guys
you know I just gotta you know but you
know I get that off my chest you know I
hear you I hear you yeah you've been
perfect though all right thanks thanks
Mark's been perfect with me every time I
hit him he's hit a home run all right
like when we did that birthday you
wanted to do with me oh yeah that was
respectful you know what I mean well you
know what that Jeffrey baldinger that
was the comic you showed yeah he's an
old pal but you guys that was probably
some Jew Bond there you know he was
trying to help out a fellow a fellow uh
thing yes I've never heard that people
benefit from being Jewish in L.A I've
never heard that that's news to me but
if you say so hear that Harvey no is
there anything I can do to change for
you guys
dude no yeah tell kalilah to stop
calling me
every night hey what are you wearing
yeah you know let me tell you something
there are Comics because we were
together for 10 years and there are
comics on Raya that match like like her
I told you this before yeah if we talked
about it on your podcast
do you let that go or what or do you
start wars I don't think you start an
open War but you you I mean look you're
mad at me over this bumpy and I say you
at least pulled a resentment against
these people he waited 10 years for that
yeah yeah yeah but no I think you go hey
you messaging what are you doing well I
think you confront casually right but
there's an actor that I really like
uh-oh I'm a huge fan and he's done my
podcast a couple times I think he's kind
of a big actor right does his name rhyme
with
who is it
[Laughter]
yeah it's so funny and then once I
brought it up because I said there's
actor and then he texted me like every
day like let's hang out let's go to the
lake
the guy was trying to [__] your wife
they always become friends they're in
your house they drink your wine yeah
yeah but one of the comics it did he
texted me frantically and I believe him
and he got him that [__] nerd yeah
but check it out this is what it is
you know the comics and actors we
photobomb on Raya so we don't even look
at the photo we just go yes yes because
rarely do they match with you anyway so
you just kind of bombard it with inner
men and it's it's a it's a numbers game
yes yes you don't really look at what
the profile photo this is his excuse
like I just [__] keep you know I mean
going yes yes this guy or the other
person you're talking he didn't say that
but the other guy was talking about uh
that makes sense but I I could I could
see that that happening but it's like
and also she's not gonna she's not gonna
[__] a comic yeah no she does it'll be
War yeah yeah it'll be [__] Warden
there's a part of you yeah the internet
right
stay out of those DMS yeah with your
eight pack well if Rife did it I would I
would get it uh like I would [__] okay
does a part of you want her to [__] a
comic just so you can sever ties and be
like it's over for sure oh or no
um well you know I here's the thing is
that I love pain
yeah you do I look I do I you know when
I was a young guy I always put myself in
unrequited love situations sure where I
really loved somebody and they want
nothing to do with me and I'll be in
those things for years and I like drive
by their you know I'm not stalker but
two in the morning it's not stalker
stuff
no like one girl name her name was
Rebecca I used to um
I'll just see her all that I don't care
her name is Rebecca I can't Sarah last
name anyway I would park outside she
lived in Pacific Beach and this is when
I was 19 20 years old I would park
outside of apartment like three in the
morning yeah you know like you know
what's his name did in Taxi Driver
Martin Scorsese
Travis [__] ranting yeah and I would
look at the silhouette of her body
through the thing but I wouldn't turn
off so that's not weird that's not weird
is that weird no no you're a fan yeah
there was a lot of like painful things
like that where I then like years later
I would try to make a move and they
would reject me and I would like cry in
a forest you know
and I mean it's I love being in that
painful spot interesting I don't do that
anymore you know now you just have your
well now I can just think I can just
[__] oh all right yeah yeah dude when
you look like when you're little like me
yeah sorry when you're a little you know
this little Korean guy right what's up
all right here you go hello hello you
like to [__] yeah right
this generation you don't get the struck
because now I go to do shows and I see
like you know a guy that looks like me
with a hot white chick and it's like a
normal thing back in the day it was a
[__] miracle it's a good point you're
a Trailblazer I was a trailblade when I
got White Post dude
I was like a king dude they made a
statue of me in Beijing yeah yeah I was
like a king you know but when you do it
it's like a normal thing so like you
know I was a trailblade Blazer I guess
you know I mean when it comes to like
but you're hooking up on the road
yeah yeah thank you so much for saying
that yeah he's cleaning up I'm cleaning
it up well I'm you know I'm not doing as
good as like some people we know
well of course of course but you know
like if you and I went like if you were
you know I know you're in love yes but
if you were it you were single and we're
both I bet you your numbers would be
better than mine well that's a different
ball game why well you're a fetish
you know it's great that was I was
waiting for what he was going to say
with the wind up and it was even meaner
than I thought it was going to be
you're right I am a fat ass dude well
you know you're a thing like Brad
Williams he does well too or he did but
he's a thing he's got the big head and
the little body and the tiny legs you're
right you're right he's a thing that's
the thing yeah my buddy is a normal
looking guy but he drives he lives in a
van so he's a van thing you know so he
gets laid because like I'll [__] a guy
in a van how funny is that right living
like a thing yeah but I don't what if I
don't want to be a thing well is it too
late it's too late it's like being a
superhero with great power comes great
response
yeah monkey or whatever spider monkey
guys so
um yeah I'm a fetish yeah but that's
cool no it's you're right because one
time I did this white chick and she goes
we're laying in bed and she goes you
know my dad used to take me to Kung Fu
festivals in the 70s and I go I don't
know why she was telling me that I go
all right she's like and I just I would
watch these kung fu movies and he was
strangely attracted to them and now I
like Asian guys
there was always a root there's a
Gateway yeah yeah they had a delicious
bowl of ramen ones
yeah and they're like oh I like the
culture the flavors or whatever I had a
Hello Kitty backpack when I was a kid
and it just stuck so yeah I guess I am a
thing
yeah but nothing wrong with that but
uh you've you're a little seasoned
so you're always
you know you just let this thing let
that sink in let that sink in I mean
that felt you're over 50. oh wait
stopped it for a second
oh so I'm seasoned yeah you've been
around the block yeah you know a thing
or two you long in the tooth you're over
the hill you're not making it better
yeah you've seen a few Winters you're
lucky Mark didn't say been around the
walk because it could have been worse I
mean I know this guy so what you're
saying is that you view me as and I want
to know this you've been around the
brook
do you view me as an older guy then I
don't yeah I think a lady likes an older
guy whoa especially the younger girl so
now you got fetish and hot a successful
older guy right am I in the same boat as
Rich Voss
well he's married and uh he's way older
and I think you're more successful I
don't think so he's a legend Richard
look at the whole picture
all right if you look at the whole
career he's way bigger than well you
both have fedoras
but yeah he's 15 years older but so I've
I'm now uh uh Elder Statesman but I
think you you have more of a sexy Vibe
he's kind of dead married guy he's out
okay okay
we were the Christmas part of the year
uh Rich Voss uh spin kick the comedian
we know who has a drinking problem and
broke his ribs no yeah which boss did
that yeah for his husband's daughter
he was he's a blackout drunk he's a guy
we're friendly with but he's a bad drunk
and he said to the he says to Rich he's
provoking him he goes I'm gonna [__]
your daughter and rich just spin kicks
him breaks his ribs put him in the
hospital yeah wow it's pretty cool you
know what it must start to get your ribs
broken by a 65 year old who wears Air
Jordan yeah it's gonna be rough who
sells CDs out of his trunk that's a
tough thing because it's like I know L.A
comics and you know guys that really
addicted to drugs and alcohol and
they're super talented and you just just
know I just don't know how to like get
through to them it's so sad you guys
have that guys like that in New York
where it's like if they just quit they'd
be the biggest thing on planet Earth
totally but they just they just can't do
it I've done everything I can but it's
like you call and go you know I'm here
if you want me to take you to a meeting
or whatever and they just don't respond
and it's just they're just dying before
your eyes but on the flip side how many
Comics have you seen get sober I've done
so many sober comedians yeah a lot a lot
like you Nikki Glazer Dan Soder Joe list
I was at the seller last night it was
like Quinn Norton I'm like yeah all
sober guys yeah yeah it's a thing now
and you the New York guys like you know
Voss Norton Kelly
those are the guys that I because you
know they have so much time
they have a lot of time sober yeah and
these are the guys that I call like
because you know I I go in and out
when's the last time the last time it
was like a year ago or two and a half
ago yeah yeah it went out it was [__]
terrible but it's like whenever I come
back it's those kind of guys that I call
you know it's so nice to know that you
have guys that like you know I mean you
can call and go I need help you can call
us too I mean we'll [__] you know
alcoholics I know but we can still chat
we can still listen I don't know I'm not
calling you guys yeah well call when you
relapse how about that yeah
yeah so wait a minute when when you do
relapse what are we talking are we
talking booze are we talking Coke are we
talking cage Special K fentanyl uh
uppers downers oxy Percocet Vicodin I
could have answered it like I know
exactly yeah
no I just drink and weed heroin I mean
I've done all those things in my life
I mean normally You're Sober what do you
mean I mean it's been a year and a half
yeah I'm completely sober now but what's
the rock bottom that gets you to stop
for this long I think the internet have
you seen YouTube lately
what happens is I um I can't stop I just
do it 24 hours a day and then the next
thing you know it's like I my light just
falls apart really quickly it says it
can't help it it's like you start losing
things immediately yeah and then you're
like oh [__] if I keep going I'm lucky
that I can see like a head so I'll just
do the math like if I'm losing this
stuff now in six months I'll lose all
these things in a year pretty much
everything so I just kind of it scares
me enough to go you know I'll nip it in
the butt now not nip that's a terrible
word
um it's a slippery slope
I love it yeah yeah but yeah I hear you
yeah yeah but um yeah so um I can see
but further down the road and I think I
wish more people could do that I mean go
yeah if my behavior is doing this now
what happens three years from now you
know right yeah yeah I don't think you
guys aren't alcoholics well we like we
drink I drink I was in Australia I drink
every night for three weeks and I'm I'm
hurting oh you are yeah it sucks plus
you lose the day you don't get to write
you know you skip the gym you're
hungover so it just has all these yeah
for two weeks the last couple weeks and
I yeah I drink every night I mean yeah
yeah it's in my rider alcohol is insane
I have wine and whiskey my Riders yeah
I'm making Manhattans I'm killing
bottles of wine you don't think it's a
problem
well uh how do you I mean how do you
feel about I I'm not judging I think I
would have more done I'd be more
productive if I didn't drink of course
yeah you would be right sometimes I look
in the mirror I'd be like man I'd be in
way better shape but what we do is we
combine work with the booze so that's
kind of one way to get a little loophole
yeah I mean I think the guy that's sort
of like blowing my mind is Burke Reiser
yeah right because like he's like I I
watch him and I go wow he's the first
guy to party the way he does and still
have an amazing [__] career in a
family usually and you lose your career
and walk out on your family and he's
just like a dad yeah parties and makes
movies he's ruining other families
because they're going no I can do it
Brooke Chrysler does it and they're like
no we're divorced you know he's an
anomaly dude he is yeah yeah I think the
word machine is
[Laughter]
and he's built the world around it he's
got the fully loaded he's got the shirt
off he's got the movies he's got the
specials yeah yeah it's all booze based
but when you guys drink though um I'm
gonna ask because you guys are both into
relationships yeah yeah
don't be scared I'm scared dude don't be
scared guys no I'm good but is it hard
because I can only imagine I couldn't do
it sober I don't know how the booze
helps a relationship I think oh really
yeah you know on the road I mean she's
not with you the whole time so no you're
at a show because you guys do theaters
and [__] you guys have a lot of fans is
it hard to like
push women away well I don't really go
out I used to go out with audience like
[__] it let's go here at the bar and you
know you try to meet a gal but now I
just I hit the show and I go to a dive
bar across town right right and I avoid
them hey I'm with Gary veterans married
and his two kids opening for me and he's
just like we need to find a restaurant
and he'll find like by the way he thinks
he's helping me he's like I found a
great restaurant I'm like oh congrats
you found a [__] 40 in entree uh
I'm with
three other dudes on the road so they're
just and they're all in relationships so
oh that's good so it's easy plus oh try
to get laid takes a lot of time no one
wants to I don't want to spend that much
time yeah getting to know people like
that's when gay guys you're so jealous
because they're just like you're hot
you're hot glory hole or whatever
[Laughter]
yeah but um let me ask you guys this um
I don't know I'm bringing this up but
um uh oh no I just I don't know how to
say it ah boy is it I'm talking to this
girl yeah right now and she's in a deep
relationship but I have feelings for her
are you [__] my wife
and we talk we talk all night you know
what I mean I don't think we have the
same taste oh right no offense yeah well
what does that mean what do you mean I
don't know what she looks like so I
don't even know like wheelchair
yeah what's your taste normally you like
a honky
I've done them you know what I mean but
then I've I've also gone you know Asian
I've gone Mexican the old one person Kai
type and it's not I've just black women
don't like me
like are you in a black woman I love
them yeah like I'll go to porn I'll
check it off to them sure yeah but
what's up it's just a funny way to say
it like a group you're like do you like
black women I jack off to them all the
time no I'm attracted I mean I just want
to say I'm attracted sure yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I would keep that out of the
sales pitch if you ever go on a date
with one uh have you ever been with a
black woman no but I've I've put in a
lot of time
yeah that's the only
um type of woman on a type I bet it's a
black woman listen to right now going
hello yeah yeah I would love it this is
actually probably the best way to get
you of Life yeah yeah I like singing out
loud yeah I would love it you know I
mean but I've just never I haven't had
the opportunity you know I mean but it
would be my pleasure to do it what's
what's the ethnicity of this woman who's
uh in a relationship right now who you
like white white I know it where'd you
meet her
I'll tell you the first time I got white
you're not gonna oh please
I'm gonna tell you the first time I got
white there what'd you do bring a hacky
sack up
I was I was a doorman at the La Jolla
comedy stuff
beautiful women in that town so back in
the night in 95 I used to be a doorman
there and I used to you know when you
were a doormat at the store
on the weekends you get one of the shows
the host which was a great opportunity
and you would do and that's how I like
met Paulie and Mencia and dice and all
these kind of guys yes because I was a
doorman down there I got to open for
them they got to see my act and they you
know they liked my I was weird yeah I'm
a weird guy you know what I mean you
know whatever you're a man that's
essentially the noise that you would see
you know what I mean yeah not that it
would make that noise but I mean yeah
they would see this like little
energetic more like a baby dolphin
[Music]
and so I went up there one night right
and there was this girl in the front of
a white girl her name was Jennifer blue
eyes and at that point I had never
hooked up with a white girl oh wow in 95
that was like hard right and then after
the what just saying hey remember you've
done it
[Laughter]
like those little cats in the Chinese
place
so then like there was no cell phones
back then so I was mopping and Fred
burns the manager yells Lee you're the
phone call and it's like one in the
morning I Go whoo some girl oh I ran
over that's exciting she goes um will
you come to Oceanside tomorrow night
let's hang out so I dropped and next
thing I know I'm in her mom's closet she
lives with her mom but she has a big
private closet with all these shoes I
remember and I was 69ing wow
this is a big closet huge closet wow and
I never 69 before whoa I did I did it
through instinct
whoa like no one ever taught me I didn't
have a master leave it to him I always
go back to numbers
you know when no I didn't even really
know what it was she was like that's 69
and I had to like see what she did
physically and then she would turn
around this way naked I go okay I'll
just you know and I kind of flowed with
it wow right and then she started
blowing me like you know and you're on
the bottom right yeah and you're like
you don't know what did no one ever
taught me so I go I think instinctually
E2 yeah
she eat why not when I'm down there yeah
right it's kind of a layup I don't know
he's giving himself a lot of credit here
for knowing to eat the [__] but it's
right there in front of you well most
guys get blown they get blown he's like
I'll get blown and but not when she's in
the 69 position already uh I'm gonna
argue against it all right if I've never
played baseball before sure right and I
hit the ball and it hit all three things
and I go to home plate and if I knew
that instinctually that'd be [__]
amazing okay Grand Slam normally like I
would hit it if they'd never seen
basically and then
probably sit back on the bench like you
don't taught you how to do that I feel
like this is like a comp though it's
like you just knowing to swing at the
ball
what never I feel like this is not the
right group for sports conversations
no I wanna I wanna argue this okay okay
all right I want to argue this all right
basically what you're saying is is that
you're not impressed right that I
instinctually knew to eat the vagina
when I was down there and all I'm
telling you is is that I literally had
never even heard of it before right so
it could have been like even though the
vagina is in front of me it could have
been like let's act it out because
all right
there
this is ridiculous I'll be the latest
all right let's do it well I got the
bottom so he moved up all right so
ridiculous we gotta open the screen all
right so I'm gonna wait before we answer
it before we even start check this out
right all right all right I'm ready yeah
all right so we're sitting there naked
like this okay right and you have to say
let's 69 no don't do that yeah okay
tell him how funny he was at the
combination
when you open for uh Mencia then he did
your same action yeah
get it Mexican so it's okay
I was gonna say if you open for dice did
she suck your dick like this
so um what are we doing now oh yeah so
my mom's got a closet right here we're
in the closet now so yeah I know what
this is yeah all right so let me blow
you no you have to say 69 because that's
blowing I knew what that was but I
thought she did she knows she goes
that's 69 I didn't know what it was but
that's my problem
yeah yeah yeah she goes that's 69 and I
go I I had to instinctually because I
can't go what is that I'm with you now
this is not impressive I thought you
said you came up with it
that's 69 right okay so I went
did that look
right and I kind of went
like how would I know did you die yeah
okay now it's my instinct right how
would I know I'll blow but the confused
like this
do you know what a 69 is wait hold on
yeah yeah you're gonna go there you go
yeah there we go okay
like this right and then I knew how to
eat that right but what I'm saying is
that no one ever taught me that it was
all instinctual so you just but you had
seen porn though Bobby right no no back
then there was no internet
okay you can get off now okay
oh I got off
[Music]
all right I don't know why we have to do
all that but I don't I don't understand
the dramatization there but yeah yeah
yeah all right I was confused but now
again anyway that was the first time I
had white [__] okay
in the closet and it was a good
experience oh no so what I was gonna say
is when I started doing it
oh imagine if somebody came up to me and
said see because I was so poor and they
said you won 10 million dollars in cash
no taxes it's all yours yeah you would
burst into tears if you're poor
that was me I was laying there I'm
eating vagina and I literally burst into
tears wow pure joy is there any way this
girl came
that wet that's so rude the way you say
that yeah there were many ways that she
could have there are many ways she could
have right and let me say something dude
I think she did I think girls love when
you cry into their [__]
by the way this is this is why this is
what men are cooler than women if a
woman cries during sex it's over all
right right okay yeah the guy cries you
keep on trucking yeah
you're here
but that was the first time and then the
second the first time I had
did you mind if I share this size yeah
please share everything the first one
the first time I had a Korean woman holy
[__] dude I don't know if I've ever had
a you've had a few Koreans yeah yeah
uh-oh those are literally no liquid it
just it won't move oh look at that yeah
yeah anyway um coagulated
oh can I have I went to a Korean
it was a what could I have a water yeah
okay I went to a Korean Camp
um yeah that sounds weird
um that sounds weird oh like a Work Camp
no no what it was it was I was on Mad TV
and these a bunch of Korean kids liked
me yeah so they go can you come out to
this camp and do like a speech like you
know be a role model yeah and one of the
camp counselors was an actress and she
was like
maybe four years younger than me she was
like at the time I can tell you what it
is um
her name is uh Patricia Lee and she was
um a Power Ranger oh she was hot no not
the one not the first one there was one
in Space the yellow ranger the [__] the
[__] by the way is it offensive that the
Asians and the black one is black yeah
is that weird yeah Dory doesn't seem to
like it
yeah that's her but when she was younger
go younger of it when she was younger
she was so hot she's cute yeah anyway
so Patricia and and um I met her and
um we made out at the camp thing right
and then we started dating hmm but I'll
tell your wife she wrote I broke up with
her
you scared the [__] out of me sideways
vagina is that a myth yeah but my dick's
sideways
it is a great movie and she was so cool
but one night I wake up I was living in
silver leg
and um there's your water she was
standing like I woke up and she was
standing at the foot of my bed staring
at me with her hair over her face oh God
right like the garage or the Ring The
Ring The Ring
and I go what the [__] are you doing
she's like oh I Sleepwalk oh right but
the way that she looked in the dark
it was so [__] scary that's terrible
how come no one ever sleep blows you
know
hammer do something
you're sleeping or sleep clean like do
something please do something exactly
sleep vacuum
it's like the Tim Allen like type
material
you don't suck I've noticed sleep taxes
or whatever
yeah it's always walking around always
yeah yeah that's it do something is what
I'm saying do something yeah here here
have you had a Korean Asian oh yeah yeah
he had a phase he had a phase you an
Asian face yeah sure yeah I'm a Jew we
do it oh yeah I mean Woody Allen went
through his own daughter that's how much
he liked I'll tell you we like Asians
he'll eats her out on Christmas yeah how
about you mark oh yeah uh two Asians in
your life yeah that's it and I don't
even know what denomination or whatever
denomination yeah yeah but uh you don't
ask I didn't yes you don't care I saw
the eyes I was in
uh but yeah it was it was great it was
great yeah I feel like they think white
guys are kind of cool oh yeah which is
rare for us it's nice to be you know
cool well no it's always been with Asian
women it's always been like um you know
they've always been fetishized and sure
always viewed as exotic sure and Asian
men have not you know through the media
and through TV shows it's only now
cleaning up in the last couple of years
where you have guys that I look at and I
go that's like Steven Yoon
oh yeah is he the guy from Lost no no
he's on uh he was in The Walking Dead
but he's on beef
guy this kid right here dude is the
future dude really he's a nope oh yeah
yeah he's sexy yeah and uh can I this
dude right here dude when he was on The
Walking Dead do you ever see The Walking
Dead how great was he in that
yeah but later bro he did five or six
seasons
and a lot of people died in that child
right but this kid right here I would
tell you at one time what a hunk he's a
hug I yelled at him once all right did
he bump you
let me get Jeffrey on the phone right
now yeah the other one's because um
when I saw him on the walking dog this
kid is our Brad Pitt yeah yeah you can
act he's handsome sweet he's got
everything sexy yeah thing right hip and
at that time I was auditioning for two
lines in these low brow comedies I would
never even get these rolls but they
always go oh two lines as a receptionist
right I would always get those honestly
right sitting there and audition this is
after The Walking Dead and he was
sitting next to me
and I looked and I'm like you're not
auditioning these two lines right he
goes yeah I am I got I pulled him
outside
and I screamed at him I go what the [__]
are you doing dude this is for me
you're a star
you mean you deserve the lead you I mean
you're talented you what you're walking
off one of the hottest shows at the time
right what do you do you know what I
mean and he he left the audition that'd
be great if you just did it to everyone
in the room until you
what do you do dude you're better than
this man you're right that's so good
that's what I should do you're a star
yeah
I get the role well Korea is having a
moment I mean you got squid game you got
parasites you got uh the other thing
yeah I think Koreans are in yeah you
remember when Trump
okay popped another Korean thing do you
remember when Trump said about parasite
he's like whatever happened to good
old-fashioned movies like Gone With the
Wind I was like dude they're still there
yeah right they make new movies yeah
yeah
I was like was killer that's [__]
good was that Park woo Park yeah
something can ho no chanto Park the
pitcher you're thinking of Matsui who's
that hideo Nomo no
yeah it is interesting that that you
know Koreans are coming out with like
really cool art oh yeah the best art out
of all of it there's no connection
though between sorry it was a silence
quiet that was my K-pop
he was holding a lot in for Ali siddique
who's been to prison
but but you know
Koreans don't [__] with American Korean
dudes
right now
not I'm like a koi fish farmer or I work
with rice like they don't really yeah
they don't know me at all yeah it's kind
of like Orthodox and non Orthodox yeah
yeah or like uh Nigerians and and um
American blacks hate each other yeah
yeah they don't [__] around it has that
Vibe yeah when people go come to Korea
I'm like all right which is fine you
know what I mean but I bet you would get
a lot of people that would still come to
see you oh yeah
the way I look
and the way I look is like you know I
mean that I have rice on my head and I
carry [__] right so they're like you
know pushing me aside you know what I
mean got it it's like in South Africa I
did shows there and before when you do
that maybe 12 years ago whatever and um
before
um the first show the promoter goes I
just want you to know that
in South Africa Asians are considered
like third class citizens
so I got what and I was always like
first on the lineup right let's just put
them up first yeah man it's also a funny
thing to say to someone right before
they go yeah just so you know you're an
animal of garbage yeah
and so then I but it was weird because
when I went up I crushed yeah I bought
no but then we would do a meet and greet
at the end
and no one would say that I was funny
wow and everyone else got it I would
watch it yeah it was so interesting at
that time it was
um
Ian bag oh yeah Pablo Francisco yep
um Jeff Dunham these are these types of
people big Comics Trevor Noah
um so um so you know that it's just
interesting you know that in other parts
of the world
you know I'm not I'm not [__] huh yeah
I'm not [__] all right well you've got
actual here dude we love you here I'm
downstairs
have you been to Australia oh they love
me though they would love you oh yeah I
know they love me there I just got back
and they they brought you up 18 times
really yeah yeah in London in England
too I guess you know I mean they they
like us there too yeah yeah white people
like you oh no they love me yeah is that
your biggest fan base you think white
people it's so [__] funny oh yeah
it's Gotta Be yeah cause joke Hoy has
like
I mean all of them come off without him
you know yeah but like when me and
Andrew on tour right now two percent one
percent is Asian what what yeah yeah you
got one right here yeah but he's you
know I mean a future one
do you have more redheads than Asians in
the crowd yeah damn I mean the Asians
that like me love me like you know you
know I did drugs too you know I'm weird
but the conservative ones that like you
know our accountants and stuff
I'm gonna say something this really
happened years ago this is so [__]
this is gonna be crazy this is crazy so
I was in the OR at The Comedy Store and
this famous Korean actor was in the
audience from America at the time he was
famous
I get upstairs and he goes let me he has
an accent let me talk to you about
something like oh this guy's gonna go
let's be be in my new movie or whatever
and he goes you disgraced no
no
people you disgrace I go why because I
showed my dick
oh yeah you show your [__] everything
I know but that's great yeah that's
called America Freedom maybe he just met
as a comedian
no but he was like you know there are
those that like look at me and they go
no
yeah but that's not us that's why we
want you to portray you know what I mean
and that's why you have certain Comics
that you know I mean aren't they're
Asian that aren't like me yeah yeah it's
like I still you know that's one white
privilege a big white privilege we have
is like no one will ever go you're not
you're not a real white no you're not
white enough you know we just I'll get
you're not a real Jew yeah but I'm
talking about white but I do think Jews
are also like grateful to have juice so
like thanks for even if you're a happy
yes one thanks for sticking around you
know yeah yeah but you know you've heard
black guys like you you ain't real black
you know and you're like well white
people don't deal with that you know
it's true yeah you're right we yeah
minorities deal with it yeah it's so
weird even women do it to each other
like hey come on you got to be uh more
girl power or whatever you're like let
me just be a woman yeah it's interesting
they do do that but you know what I
don't listen to it I just do what I do I
can't be anything that I'm not yeah I
can't I I just
I say it on stage I say it the way I say
it now right and I do what instinctually
think I think is funny and then people
go I don't like it it's fine I can't do
anything else sing it sister I mean uh
I've sucked it before people know that I
suck three penises in my life yeah they
came in my mouth but you know there were
accidents I'm not gay yeah I think it's
weird that one wasn't in the closet yeah
like I've done weird things I've done
math I've done you know I mean I've you
know sorry yeah you know what I mean how
was math
you're great
it's one of the best drugs ever as an
age you say meth or math
wait when did you do math in high school
damn that's like throwback I went to a
rehab specifically for math bot whoa
yeah it was well I did I started doing
drugs at like 11. like drinking smoking
weed at 11. damn but meth is a very
white guy drug when I grew up in um
Poway at the time I mean there was a lot
of meth going around okay and it was
like easy to get and uh whatever the
[__] is Poway what is that a place
Poway in Korea Oh I thought you grew up
in America no poly Korea you never heard
Poway no yeah it's in San Diego
I'm the Google guy here
hey dude you're [__] racist okay
racist
like a little town called Poway up it's
like a suburb of San Diego yeah
you were young as hell in rehab how did
that was your parents were like you got
to go to rehab
yeah when I well I mean I didn't I
wasn't at 16 is the first time I went to
rehab yeah and I went to three between
16 and 17 and then when I was 17 I went
to a place called McDonald's Center I
got sober there damn yeah well why
why I'm I'm curious I I I think because
I um I had such a brutal
um childhood because my dad was so
[__] violent and I was always so
sensitive I was like born sensitive you
know and and to see him like beat the
[__] out of my mom and us and like and
you're always constantly like that's why
like when I walk into like a restaurant
I have to know where the exits are wow
yeah I have to yeah I'm always like that
like where do I escape let me just say
this yeah all right [__] I thought
that'd be louder
can you wait till he's done telling the
story about his violent Father Mark I
cut the tension a little bit and that's
what my father used to beat my mother
hold on let me get that real quick well
keep talking this is for America you're
gonna kill me [__] Poway welcome here
with no one molest children or beats
their moms well you had you guys had
great childhoods
it was mixed but it was good yeah yeah
salad
that was all right I had a weird
childhood black neighborhood uh the
white family transvestite Nanny whoa
yeah cool I mean we talked about a new
podcast it was a blended family there
was there was weirdness but it wasn't
like [__] I mean yeah did you skate too
like him no I played basketball yeah I'm
whatever are you still skating or no no
I'm too old and
crunchy I can't do it my body's still it
looks so good you skate no I'm a huge
fan of the sport huge fan and there
these kids now are unreal like even the
ladies yeah killing it dude killing it
what's so funny
that sounded success right yeah oh [__]
it's my misogyny joke alarm I'll do
something else oh there we go yeah I
can't drink this I mean I did I'm not
gonna catch up Mark I'm not into it it's
I'm gonna be the only drunk one here
sorry you're talented you're good at
what you're doing I'm fascinated just
because you know you breaking the
sobriety that we is a drinking podcast
it just it was interesting to me the the
rehab yeah I mean how scary are there
people screaming at night you gotta you
got a guy in your room with you is he
trying to fight you are people jonesing
are they scratching their necks well I
mean the McDonald's there's a corporate
like it's on scripts you know what I
mean so it's like pretty corporate you
were like you know in the pajamas and uh
if you look early on in my Instagram I
have a photo of me at the McDonald's
Center wearing my pajamas and stuff
um yeah it was uh cool until and then
when I was I'll show you a photo oh cool
I just I literally just and then um so
when I was 17 I went to the McDonald's
Center and then um and I was like and I
met this man
and he changed my life and I want to
show you a photo of this man
all right what so this man right here
Jesus this man right here changed my
life hey was he in the hab no he was a a
dude that was Korean who was adopted
from Korea and he was sober for a very
long time at the time like Mr 12 stop
and he came to the rehab because he
found out there was a Korean kid there
whoa and he once we locked eyes he was
just like I'm gonna be her I'm gonna I'm
gonna take care of you
and I just I had breakfast with him last
week so we still and this is in
1988 when I met him yeah and he's still
a part of my life and I just had
breakfast with him last week he's like I
did my dad damn yeah but he um he
the dude saved my life there was a lot
of men back then that like really just
because you know they knew that I had a
violent childhood and you know stand-up
only happened because I was at a a
meeting when I was 22 and I spoke at an
a meeting and I crushed
I like it was like one of those like
gigantic speaker movie meetings or like
let the kid have to be the first Speaker
yeah I crushed dude you're amazing yeah
that was my first kill and when I went
off stage a bunch of like older like a
dudes walked into me goes hey kid you
should do comedy whoa you pulled your
dick out of me
[Laughter]
yeah but then um and then a year later
or whatever I you know I started doing
open mics but yeah I got a lot from that
hope just being in that environment and
people encouraging me so I did you know
I did my first seven years
um of stand up completely sober it's
only when I got mad tv when I relapped
again interesting was it just that
grueling
that's got to be tough being on Fox it
was a terrible really one of the worst
um times of my life whoa I remember
average Asian dude you were [__] I
like that yeah that was good that was a
good one pull it up
oh man it's not good I don't remember
the average age yeah
it's just like a sketch oh it's funny
though yeah before the time oh my god oh
this is exciting
you don't want to spend the summer the
grocery store or prepping meals let's
Factor do the cooking for you yeah you
keep crushing your health goals Factor
America's number one ready to eat meal
kit delivers nutritious meals straight
to your door it's the easiest way to
stay on track while saving tons of time
I've tried their stuff it's pretty damn
good oh yeah I like them I love the
smoothies they're good I'm a big fan
love Factor always fresh never Frozen
takes two minutes to prepare yeah I mean
every I had a ton of these and they're
all really good you need extra boost to
support your Wellness goals this summer
try Protein Plus meals with 30 grams of
protein or more per serving you don't
have time to cook you don't always have
you don't want to waste super amount of
money uh doing seamless yeah all those
hidden charges you order a [__]
Italian sub it's 47 exactly exactly
where the hell is the money going Factor
meals come in a variety of Lifestyle
options if you're vegan vegetarian keto
calorie counting there's something
delicious waiting for you head to factor
meals.com
drunk50 and use coat use the code drunk
50 to get 50 off your first box that's a
lot that's it I mean that's big some of
these discounts you're not getting that
so 50 off
that's code drunk 50 at Factor meals.com
drunk50 50 off your first box that is a
great deal
again oh is that with Alex bold and we
were drinking doing shots oh that guy
can't stop I don't know he loves a
shooter
all right oh okay I'm a little hungover
I need a drink and a shirt oh I got your
shirt with that new Merchant we might be
drunkpod.com all kinds of cool stuff
this shirt this shirt and of course I
got a drink for you oh beautiful Bodega
cat whiskey don't drink responsibly
because we make more money if you don't
yes you got that right keep driving
okay
that was a different time like Ike
[Music]
so cute
the 90s
um hi Sandra I brought you a little gift
[Music]
it's not a fire breathing dragon it's a
bottle of wine the guy at the liquor
store just wrapped it up for me
you're so funny don't be humble we all
know that your crowd does fancy things
with paper
make me a swan
[Music]
that's great
we gotta bring this back all right let's
turn it off all right we go I hate
watching my show I guess I was so scared
then what were you 20 something I was
29. oh okay yeah yeah but I um
you know when I went I got on that show
like everyone I had never done acting on
it really and I had never done sketch or
anything like that and it's like I had
to like I didn't know what a Mark was
sure you know what a mark is Norman yeah
but no yeah yeah so then like I didn't
know what a jib camera right so
everything I learned you know what I
mean was on that show but I would fail a
lot and it was really hard and you know
I mean I've said this before but the
second day I was there you know somebody
called me in a producer and he goes I
just don't think you're funny oh wow
then he goes uh I just don't think
you're funny you're not right for the
show and I I've been I'm just one guy
that I try to not you know I was like
against you being the same guy from
South Africa he was like you're just not
he's just not working and then when he
said that I was just like yeah I just
knew when he was saying that in his
office I turned around and I literally
started crying and I I relapsed that
night just like your 69 experience yeah
yeah
but different you know the feeling was
different wow for you uh I mean what
here's my question why would he say that
to you you're on the show
I remember at the time they were like
the only reason why I even got an
audition was because my manager managed
one of The Producers Lauren Dombrowski
and you know no one like an agent
wouldn't sign me I didn't have any agent
or anything right I just had a manager
she couldn't get me an agent so I was
just like you know I just I work at the
store and I go well can you at least I
don't even know what it's like to
audition for a TV show so can I just at
least audition for one and she called
Lauren she basically goes like I have a
client he's new and he's just gonna he
wants to practice what was your audition
do you remember yeah it was like three
characters and three Impressions yeah
that night that's pretty cool that night
yeah because I choose because my manager
was like you're not gonna get the show
they want a white guy you know I mean
that's what they want they want someone
young different time yeah and they're
like you know but they will see you just
to practice so I remember first showing
up there going in and there was like no
one else there and you know they weren't
like even like when I walked into the
room they were just kind of like all
right let's let's go oh yeah and then
you know I think that my second
character they just kind of the woman
that was in there I love her so much uh
Nicole Garcia she she kind of tilted her
head she's like that's [__] funny
and so afterwards she's like yo can you
come back next week and I go really
it's like yeah like but I don't like
these things you did change these and
come back so I went back the next week
and then she was like better but take
this out do this and every week she
would call me in ah to the point where
it was like 9 10 11 I don't remember but
it was like a lot a lot but then by the
time I was like at the end there was
more and more people in the room yeah
and less and less people in the lobby
and they and then it came down to me and
tear and kill him wow was in high school
what yeah and I was remembering at Fox
but just between him and I and they were
like taryn's gonna get it yeah but we
both got it oh wow well that's how I got
in yeah it was like what sorry I was
just did you tell Karen in the lobby
you're better than this I need this
he was like he was in high school and he
was so funny but I remember just going
like you know
here's the thing I learned you just you
got to just try yeah there you go you
never know you know it's like that old
saying you know you like suit up and
show up and do the best you can if you
don't walk through fear if you don't
like just try yeah nothing happens here
here
let me know if you like and then I'll
tell you what it is you gotta just try
yeah yeah it's like uh it's like a
bodega cat Mai Tai kind of situation
very good like when you guys did stand
up for the first time yeah how scary was
it terrifying and you get drunk yeah but
you did it yes and that's funny I got
drunk too for my first one it was
horrifying and it took me about six
months to do it again that's how scary
it was yeah it was and I bombed so hard
that it was like PTSD I couldn't get
back up but it took six months to get
over it were you when you relapsed that
night he said that to you like were you
just [__] wrecked the whole time
you're on the show or what was that so
two years in so I I was using on that
show for two years
and it got like really bad like to the
point where one time they I did this
sketch That was supposed to um shoot at
um Griffith Park
and it was like you know the big crew
and I was the lead of the sketch I just
never even showed up damn I was in
Tijuana
um smuggling drugs through the Border
what yeah what type bottles of like
Valium and Somas and
um and I would take the cotton out no I
would put more cotton in and then
tighten it so they wouldn't Rattle and
then I would tape it to my body and I
would walk across so that it wouldn't
buzz you know what I mean even from
average Asian to Midnight Express
and I remember one night I was like I I
was smuggling and then I go I took like
four volumes like a super drunk and then
I woke up in this hotel room by the
border and I remember you know we had
cell phones the newer versions of it and
I remember going to my voicemail there
was like 50 [__] boys like oh my God
where the [__] are you where the [__]
yeah I mean and that was like a constant
and the reason why they wouldn't fire me
at the time was because I was the only
ethnic guy on any of their TV shows on
Fox right so they were like and at the
end black people on Cops
I was like the only non-whiter black guy
you know what I mean that was like on
really at the time any show I think um I
think there was one I think Sandra Oh
was on Gray's Anatomy or whatever but
yeah I mean but rare but for Fox it was
rare that's true like we need to hold on
to the you know the China event or
whatever you know yeah yeah and this is
when like you know it was sort of
opening up for us yeah so then um at the
end of the second season they gave me an
intervention
the network and the producers and it was
on a Monday and I remember I was wearing
a turtleneck whoa like I was sweating
and they're like yeah you're about to
get fired and we we also need you
because the weird thing was is because I
was so different
that the fans really loved me like I I
like if I walk in from the audience I
would get the ones even though it was
all drugged addicted yeah yeah and so
then um they go can you do one sketch
and I've told the story before can I
tell it again please
[Laughter]
start from here yeah and cut here um
so
um they go we we wrote us Connie Chung
sketch for you and I go um okay and they
go it's we're shooting live Friday can
you just stay sober enough to do the
sketch and I was taking like 30 to 40
Vikings a day
so I by the way this is the funniest
reason to drop the pills yeah it gotta
be Connie yes did you ever party with
Artie Lang because he was a [__] no
that was way before that was way before
already Lang was [__] great on Mad TV
it was great that's my white Mama yeah
so then I called a guy named Duncan
Trussell oh I love Duncan so don't
control I go you gotta come to my
apartment and wipe out my house of drugs
he came over in like 30 seconds and he
lives like three hours away what a guy
he just showed up he went through my
whole apartment he's like the wolf in
Pulp Fiction
I think he made me a fish dinner I don't
know why but he really did he made he
bought fish he made a fish dinner this
seems like one of the best dudes he's a
great guy great guy I only know of him
I've did his podcast a few times and I
just like loved him yeah he's great he
just seems cool and he had like a bag
bags full of pills yeah he's like later
right and then sounds like a Tuesday by
Thursday I was a mess dude I was like
shaking right
and then by Friday I felt a little
better and then um but I remember doing
the Connie Chung rehearsal and I was
sweating a lot where they had to keep
you know I mean adding the makeup and
this and that
and then
um
live happened and I um I'm out in front
of the crowd it was like 400 500 people
in the audience whatever TV audience and
it's the lights are out right and
they're like three two one and Bruce
lady the director was like action the
lights come out and as soon as the
lights came out I just knew I couldn't
do it
I just knew like every line that I had
which is completely gone we didn't have
teleprompters back then for like doing
these monologues you had to memorize
them right and I was like and I went
good evening
I go I'm Connie and as I said as I said
I said Connie
my stockings were being filled with [__]
[Applause]
you were just panicking I [__] my pants
wow and it was like you know stockings
and you could see the [__] you know I
mean roll down my stockings the next
thing I know
they're dragging me offset
[Laughter]
and I remember being dragged off and I
remember my manager being there she's
I'm still with Abby and I just remember
people that's in my face and it's just
like Charlie brownie you know what I
mean yeah and it was just like and I'm
like it's over like like my everything's
done my career is over life is over
and I remember being in my dressing room
and then Abby is just like we got to
take you to a hospital tomorrow so they
drove me to this place in San Diego
and that got sober and then what
happened was a miracle happened
so two months in
I was going to meetings I was like two
months sober this is the summer
and they fired me for mad and I was in
an a meeting isn't that a bad luck to
fire someone for being clearly having a
drug problem and not giving them a
chance to get help I I don't know
probably not back then I love how
they're like we love you we care about
you but quickly come to this Asian
stereotype
of Charlie's Angels okay yeah yeah and I
was in I was in a meeting and I look
across the meeting and
you know Lauren was you know the one of
The Producers my you know and uh she was
she looked at me and she goes
wow oh you have a sponsor I go and her
her husband starts sponsoring me one of
the prisoners of mad and then a month
later I just remember Lauren call me
because listen
you really you're really doing it I
convinced Fox to give you you know just
like a trial run
my third year so but what I did my third
year was completely different like
usually on Mondays you pitch and I
wouldn't go because they wouldn't listen
to my pictures right but now that I was
like sober again and stuff like I'm
gonna stay here till two in the morning
until they listen to me and if they
didn't write me into sketch I would like
write my own I learned how to write on
my own but what I learned to do was
shoot things on my own so I started
shooting sketches on my own I like I do
this thing called Bobby 24 with Bobby
Lee because 24 was such a Big Show and
Bob 24 to the 24th
um sketches that I did were popular but
I filmed the first one because they
wouldn't write it so I you know bought a
camera I had my neighbors and people
like help me and then what happened was
I [__] brought that thing in to a
table read and I said to Dick platuchi
the executive producer I go can you just
air
sorry they're not very loud today
I know I think that's what's sad about
it
that's what really bothers me yeah like
the comedy's lost from it yeah you're
right yeah because you can't even hear
it they're sad I thought they'd be loud
but I didn't want to [__] my stockings
it's like it's like an action movie when
a guy is uh when he's had a bullet yeah
right so anyway I went to a table read
like oh I I filmed the sketch on there
on like we don't do it that way I go but
can you just air I think you'll like it
and so at the end of the table read you
know the the the Network's there all the
writers everyone yeah they bring in a TV
and they put in of each a VHS tape of
the thing that I [__] shot yeah and
it murdered
and then they go you know we're gonna
add some stuff to it but when it leave
it as is
so what I filmed is what a lot a lot of
what they used on the show and so you
know the show started going you know
we're just gonna put Bobby Lee into
sketches so Bobby Lee in the wild Bobby
Lee doing this and I could play myself
right so that's how that whole thing
started it leaves the pressure a little
bit Yeah performance anxiety so you're
back you're rehired yeah I was on it for
six more years wow that's unheard of
yeah yeah look at that was that producer
who told you you weren't funny
I have a sketch I don't want to see his
name because I'm not gonna because I
love the guy oh you're friends with the
guy now I love him because
one of my most popular sketches online
he wrote and it's called Dragon Hunter 2
you know what I mean and you can go
don't don't play it now but like you
know I mean he wrote me bangers after
that hey all right yeah I know did you
ever talk where he goes out no no no you
know what I'll be honest with you I
sucked he was doing that out of love
probably i s I was [__] terrible dude
I really was I I didn't I wasn't ready
for a TV show yeah I mean I I because of
my Charisma and my commitment when I
perform I convince all these people to
get me on the show but when I showed up
at the show I mean I'm doing a show with
groundling yeah I mean main company guys
right right Mike McDonald like Michael
Hitchcock's a writer a writer on the
show I mean everywhere that went on
there are like sketch gods and if they
were stand-ups they were like Frank
Caliendo who's a master impressionism
Mary Spears is a great impressionist
yeah I I I I didn't know how to do
anything yeah you know I mean I just had
the thing of like I'm gonna go for it
yeah Vibe like I'm gung-ho which is I
think at the end that's always worked
for me gung-ho is your uncle but uh
yeah so anyway I mean it's not funny but
I just no that's [__] fascinating
that's that's a great story did you hear
about these John Belushi's or Chris
Farley's you got out you could have gone
that way yeah I could have I could have
died yeah wow yeah it was amazing and
then um too bad a Korean man who saved
you didn't give a [__] about white
people or we could still have Chris
Farley yes good point that's right yeah
good point yeah but it's interesting you
know and but yeah I slip you know and
then after that I got you know after 17
I got stayed sober for 17 years wow from
that Connie Chung thing to
um and then I relapsed again so it's
like it can happen but it's pretty far
away 17 years though and you how long
was did you fall off for I I can last
about three or four months yeah I think
that's fair look at Santino I mean like
one time we were in [__] Cancun he
opens the door to my hotel room and
there's poo smeared on the walls there's
poo all over my body vomit then I'm like
confused
I'm like what's going where am I she's
cool over my hands that's
yeah yeah I mean I just I get drunk and
I just black out and you know I mean and
I just things happen and you do it in
secret like because Android I've drank
with Andrew a bunch yeah he's like he's
like a drinker like us he's a good drunk
he's a good drunk yeah yeah no I do a
private layer yeah you know just chop
chop chat
and I poo on myself and I go I make you
know man yeah face pit makeup you know
what I mean
I kind of want to party with you now I
mean it sounds pretty fun but yeah I'm a
mess dude whoa I'm glad how long have we
done
all right then well we cut a lot out you
know we made a lot of let's go let's
keep going but yeah how long do you
usually go to an hour and a half yeah
yeah sorry I [__] up the moment no you
have shows nothing oh okay great I
appreciate you being so open and
vulnerable man I mean well no because
some of these stores I've told before I
just I feel like I don't want to like
you know man I want to hear something
new but like you know I mean I haven't
told that story in years but no it's a
great story yeah it's also like I didn't
mean to laugh when you say that it's so
tragic that it's like one of the things
I think about I'm like what a bad set
but I didn't [__] my pants yeah that's
the good thing I actually think
sometimes yeah it could have been worse
I could have [__] myself and you
actually [__] yourself it's crazy yeah
but that's the problem with being sober
is you get less stories when you're
drinking and doing pills and meth you
know that's a great Jim Jefferies joke
yeah all the all those stories end with
and then I got home yeah
I love that I mean things happen
in this sobriety I've had the craziest
year
a [__] imaginable oh really yeah like
I had that me and kaleido break out yeah
that was wild yeah that war with Brendan
Schaub yeah there was some canceling
things that we're still going or is it
no that ended but I'm just saying so
much [__] happened this year but great
things happen as well oh I hope so and
when you when you go out and you try to
live a big life big things happen big or
good or bad good or bad and I and I I
just kind of like you know
stay like this I try to I mean you know
I've been sad and super sad this year
but I've been super happy and it's just
been it's a roller coaster it's a roller
coaster but I have a big live and um I
don't I I love it all right I love every
single moment of it because it's like
well you like the pain which I I don't I
don't dig what do you mean the pain you
said you like the pain you go in the
woods you cry no that was back in the
day that was a little [__] but like all
I'm saying is it's like no I mean I
don't like pain oh okay yeah yeah and I
don't like um but here's the deal dude
it's like
it's what Missy used to say to me man
you know she said to me years ago
she goes I was driving around when she
used to come down to San Diego and me
and Freddie Soto used to drive around
town you know what I mean we go to
steakhouses and stuff and we're in my
comedy store shirt and stuff and she one
night we're at Bully's restaurant
and she goes you know what makes a star
you know and I go what she goes half the
people have to love you let half the
people have to hate you as well
interesting right you just got to keep
them talking
and I go and I didn't know what she
meant by then but I think I have a
better understanding of it now yeah I
mean Reggie Jackson said he ain't nobody
till somebody hates you yeah or
something like that but I just watched
the John Mcenroe documentary oh wow
everybody hated him but everybody loved
him too he's throwing the rights yeah
some of the Knicks came a few weeks ago
and he like didn't remember me at all
but I [__] bombed one of his dumb
benefits oh I did one of his two oh my
God worst worst crowds of all time oh my
God I remember I did get a big laugh out
of him though I remember this yeah these
women just in the front room just
talking my entire set I go somebody go
lady shut the [__] up and I see
Macklemore go yes
or nightmares why do you guys do those
they pay well no that was a charity game
very well oh did it I did one like two
months ago it was killer and he was in
the front row and he was great but yeah
like I did one for free it was like a
benefit I mean it was like you know but
I mean aren't you at a point where you
can go you know I know it's a lot of
money but yeah
when I did it was no money I mean I did
literally do because they were like it's
for his charity so I was like yeah I'll
do a free gig for a charity so you're
willing to do anything like a nightmare
gig I just did the worst corporate I
mean I've done some bad corporates yeah
and I did one in Toronto not too long
ago I bombed for an hour and 20 straight
like not one not a heck why'd you do the
extra 20. I was trying to get a laugh to
end on yeah I'm trying to get out of
there yeah yeah it was brutal brutal and
the guy this is the worst part the guy
in the beginning was like I'm a huge fan
can you do that joke can you do that
these quoting jokes I'm like this is
gonna be a [__] Cakewalk I got the
jokes he likes me I'm gold and he ran
the whole company I did all the jokes he
said they all bombed and he's looking at
me going
they don't realize that it's not it's
not always the way it should be they
they just they're like I've seen those
jokes work and you're like exactly yeah
I know I don't know it's the environment
I'm in but also I was doing gigs in
Toronto I said I'll pop over and do this
corporate make a nice check and then
leave but did they ask they give you
rules like you can't do this you can't
nothing nothing I asked that ahead of
time so you can talk about anything
anything and I did I get booked on a
corporate or a private event they
usually book us knowing there's no rules
because if they're a fan of what we do
right right yeah you know but it's so
funny you guys haven't gone tour
together
there's more money to be made alone I
don't think so oh
oh you and the old uh Ginger huh yeah me
and ginger yeah we realize now because
there are people like the incentive of
like oh Sam we love them but but
together they're like some people are
like you know what I'm willing to take
the day off of work or travel further or
you know what I mean all right it
becomes more special right right and I'm
telling you you guys it would be like a
super tour if we added like you know
Stavros or something right oh my God you
guys would [__] kill it I mean that's
what Tim Dylan and and I mean look I've
talked to Chris Devin I was trying to
get me to do it with him oh really it's
like you know I talked to my agent he
was like you stop oh that'd be huge my
only fear with us is the carryover he's
probably right it's like
it probably would be bigger money and we
could do 20-minute sets when we're
building a new app oh yeah and and we
you know yeah we get to hang out yeah
and then we improvise at the end you
know I mean it's like so easy and like
you know if I go to a place I could
probably sell a 2 000 seat you know what
I mean but now we're selling four or
five thousand seats together right and
it's like and it's less pressure it's
more of an event yeah and um it's a lot
of fun man I think we do it for like
every city because you there's certain
cities you want to do alone but I think
like certain cities we could do it I'm
done everywhere I go they go samaroo we
might be drunk whatever yeah I mean I
think I think we did certain cities
together it'd be it'd be a good
experiment I'm down I'm down and if we
did like a super group like you me stuff
and like Chris or you me stop and Mateo
or someone like oh yeah whoever yeah I'm
available too man
it's so [__] up what you're just doing
right now we could do we could do we
could do a super uh we might be bad
yeah yeah
that would be amazing that's the show we
might be bad that's funny and then we
could play like a bigger way bigger
places I love it because you know Tom
seguro asked me to open for him in
Canada and usually it's like oh you know
I had a cold open this is six months ago
but that's a big arena or something it
doesn't yeah I know and in my mind I'm
like this is gonna be a nightmare and
why am I even doing this but it's like
what you don't understand is that we're
all family
we really are I mean you know so many of
my fans are your fans you have you know
people that only like you that's fine
right but it's like we're all in the
same pot right yeah and so when we go
out together it makes sense also we draw
a draw out like there's people that
really love tiger ballet that might
aren't familiar with you right right but
if we we we're all together you'll gain
more fans because my people would look
at you and vice versa it just it's it's
great so when I open for top I couldn't
believe it like we're playing these
stadiums like 15 000 seats or whatever
and I'm cold opening and the lights
would turn on they would say my name and
the place would erupt wow and I was just
like I couldn't believe it and I was
like what the [__] it felt like I was
Korean Elvis man that's that's what
comedy has that it didn't have before
yeah it has that now it has that now
that crossover thing of like they know
Theo Vaughn they know Santino they know
Segura they know you they know Bert they
know everybody they know stop they know
Gillis yeah and it wasn't like that
before you go I like Seinfeld I like
Dave Chappelle I like Chris Rock but it
wasn't this family
last night Shane Gillis ran his hour me
and Andrew opened oh and when we walked
out they didn't know we were going to be
there and the place went erupted it's
like it's beautiful it makes sense we're
all a family that's why I'm here yeah
you think I want to come here
North Koreans and stuff like you know me
but I came here because I want to see my
brothers
you always Man true you've always been a
good dude you are you are in a rare
sincere moment on the spot you're a good
guy
we did an episode before that yeah this
ain't no
hey man you're a good guy I love you
you're a good man now that would be fun
to do those types of uh gigs though yeah
yeah no we should do it well in any
version of it you know I mean it's like
you guys should go out together you too
we should I even did a couple like you
know I did a few gigs with Adam Sandler
I opened that those shows and it was
like I got messages like holy [__] we
did not expect this many abortion jokes
on an Adam Sandler show but they get the
people like holy [__] I I'm a fan of
yours and you know I saw you here so you
do get those like it is weird when that
crossover Works anywhere yeah you know
yeah but in the podcast world it's
different because it's like we do each
other's podcasts
they do expect it sometimes but I'm sure
like to see you and put and Santino on
this on chain show is like an insane
great pop but I think you're right
though with the Seinfeld is now doing
tours with Gaffigan yeah you saw that
and then Sandler does Spade Schneider
Apatow the show that's the shows I did
Kevin James Kevin James he was on that
one but one of the ones I did was like
Apatow uh Spade Schneider hosts wow uh
but even more though Nick was on that
one Nick's on some of them okay but even
though we when bad friends were in
Detroit Sandler called us and goes come
out and eat with us yeah so me and Sam
me and Andrew went to go see eat with uh
Kevin James and is that all those guys
but my point though is that even they
the ones that are like they know they
understand that this is now you know I
mean a move like a lot of movements I
don't want to sound like like that but
it is a thing it's a thing right and
they can't ignore it almost I love it
there's so many guys that like you would
never used to even give me the time of
day yes that are now like waving at me
you know what I mean and I want to go
[__] you piece of [__] but I go way back
because I'm a coward we have the
internet exactly
the nicest guy in the world he's like
the best dude he's a [__] class man
you know all the Legends I've met in my
life Carlin I've met yeah
class I'll tell you my problems where I
was in the 90s I was back door at the
Hollywood comedy store and I check ideas
and one weekend he did a weekend there
wow and he came in and I was sitting
there I was so scared because I'm yeah
I'll blow him yeah I mean like a little
snake bite on his dick and he's like I
need you know well that's an emergency
that's yeah but I wouldn't so like this
kind I don't go [__] I like you but
I'm just saying I'm gonna suck your dick
but my point is that's crazy in the
Korean no way no my point is is that so
Carling Walks By Me Goes
what's your name Kid ah Bobby Lee and he
goes comic I go yeah and he goes cool
and he did a set a year later I'm still
working the back door and he does the
weekend again
and he walk he doesn't say hi to me no
he does that he walks up and he goes Mr
Lee and he walked right past me I mean
in his defense pretty good odds
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
a safe forget everything I met him too
he says he's a cool dude he's a sweet
guy and he gave a [__] yeah you gave a
[__] yeah he said Mr Lee
yeah yeah two other like icons that you
met that were you were like that dude's
cool I bet Eddie Murphy's nice guy
um cool yeah I've met um I mean I don't
wanna there's some guys are pieces of
[__] too though oh yeah and they're
never as funny what the meanest guys
aren't as funny we can believe the name
but who's like a piece of [__] well I
could cover my mouth and bleep it yeah
I mean he's just kind of like I don't
like them are you being real no I'm a
I'm a fan you know he's talented I'm not
saying that but there's just not he
doesn't go down right like some of these
guys will dig deep well no they'll reach
down and go talk to the like for me it's
like anyone that I see coming up that's
good
I'm always reaching my hand down and
going you know I mean I think you're
doing great work and and you know I'm
proud of you or whatever you know I mean
that's just the way it should work but
there are certain guys that are older
that just they just don't act like like
I'll just say this now I don't care like
Martin Lawrence like I've opened her
before he doesn't never talk to me
before in my life right right I was in a
green room with Mark Lawrence once and
he was talking through his Road manager
and then giving me instructions of and
he was like sitting right there uh you
mean that type of mentality it's like
you know I've been around a lot of weird
swords you know what I mean yeah and you
know back then you know they were like
huge Hollywood famous guys right but I
think in the day in the age of the
internet you can't have that kind of
vibe right because it's like you never
know I mean like this little North
Korean over here next you know like he's
the biggest violinist yeah you never you
never know right and you know and
there's no the road is like it's
ambiguous because it's like anyone can
make it at any time I know so you just
got to be nice and you know what I mean
I'm nice to try to be nice to everybody
I completely agree and you know they're
human beings
you could be just cool because yeah it's
the right thing to do yeah you'd just be
nice yeah yeah but like um but you are
you've always been cool you've always
been an easy going dude yeah yeah I did
a movie with um
I was scared because I did a movie with
like sometimes you do movies with like
real Hollywood people oh yeah so I did a
movie with Kate Blanchette and Jamie Lee
Curtis and we were in Hungary for two
months wow right and I remember this is
unbelievable I remember we having lunch
in like Kate's right here and Jamie Lee
Curtis is right here and I told the joke
I forgot what the joke was and everyone
laughed and then Kate kind of rubbed my
back whoa right you know and I was like
you and you know as a like a comic
you're like this is [__] cool right
yeah but in my head I was like they're
just cool right like if you know I've
done movies with stars that won't even
talk to you yes but some some of you
cover your mouth who are they what oh
look at that that's a great pick with
pen and tell that was me and Jamie yeah
and we went to Burger King what yeah
Jamie Lee Curtis like let's go to Burger
King she at Burger King yeah damn she's
so cool great tips and then they invited
me to
can't deny it and then they invited me
to a synagogue with a little hat you
know what I mean ah the yamaka yeah
because yeah but it was like it's cool
and then sometimes you do things and you
know they're a little distant but yeah
okay blanchett's cool [__] oh my god
dude she's she's I got I think a lot of
acting's [__] but when you're that
good yeah yeah I know and she is that
good she's the best she's great and also
and she's still pretty hot sexy lady hot
but she's also funny yeah like she says
dark [__] yeah I love that all right oh
cool that was an angel I'm not that she
did one but I'm just saying that yeah no
no print that you heard it yeah
[Laughter]
a lot of
wow a lot of [__] jokes okay Jesus
another guy I could work with that was
cool was Ben Kingsley oh he's a beast
like he's just like the nicest guy you
know sexy sexy [__] yeah you know it's
great about us is that like when we're
in those environments don't you feel
like we don't believe I like it there's
a part of course of course I like this
was a mistake yes I shouldn't be here so
it's like I feel like you know what
whatever it's like we we have our lane
and then you get those weird
opportunities and they're cool [__] yeah
man we have a land don't we not and they
wish they could do what we do they can't
go on stage for an hour it's a different
thing I mean different thing but you're
also there because like but they want to
be us better I'd rather be us than them
I mean look they're they're Millionaires
and famous and all that but like I'd
rather be a comic I like that I can make
my own schedule my career and I can be
like I feel like touring this time and
just work I love that I love that I'm
not waiting on someone to write me
something yes yeah yes an audition and
you can be you like if a joke bombs you
can go well that bombed all right [__]
you man whatever they can't do any of
that I gotta stay in that little box
exactly I have mad respect for Ben
Kingsley I love it but but at the same
time like I yeah I'd rather be a comedy
I love comedy easily I mean Brad Pitt I
think wants to be a comedian you know
he's a funny guy I've never met him but
I I think that some of his performances
are like very fun he understands comedy
he does in Burn After Reading yeah that
was the movie I was gonna bring up yeah
there was a scene where he's like
listening to music yeah in the car and
he was like doing this weird thing yeah
and they were like really funny choices
and I'm like dude that guy is [__]
funny the [__] treadmill yeah and
that won't be right so [__] funny
underrated that's an underrated comb
brother I love that [__] movie great
movie it's a great [__] I love the Cohn
Brothers yeah there we go that yeah that
dude he's so funny in that movie he's
great Clooney's funny in that [__] yeah
he's funny too but I think that um but
he's also a big comedy fan who Brad yeah
yeah oh yeah I mean Chicago played in La
he showed up that's right yeah yeah
he also did Dave oh he was on Dave yeah
he's just a date whoa they did the whole
episode they all want to be funny they
all do you see you in a bullet train
yeah he's good he was hilarious pretty
good bullet training there you go I
didn't like that movie but really did
you like it I thought it was pretty
funny yeah it feels like a plane movie
dude I'm trying to watch the [__] uh
that white TV show but everyone said
what's uh it's called um yellow Stones
you don't like it oh that's white [__]
that's like rednecks I like the first
couple seasons and then after that I
never said I'm watching the first for
the fourth time trying to watch the
first episode but let me ask you
something does it get good because it's
about land and property it's like I
don't know
if that show will turn you into a
republican what yeah it's it's you watch
and you're like dude they can't just
take his land
that's his land all right right all
right he should have the whole state of
Montana that's fair is it good does it
get better I think the first couple
seasons are good I I don't I think it
gets a little off the charts like the
the daughter is so over the top yeah
there's certain times I'm like I mean
look I love that you're naked and that
you're and that you're hot and over
there but like she's so over the top
yeah I'm like
I it's not believable it's it to me it's
like succession like violent dumbed down
succession's amazing I love success I
love secession do you see the last one
yeah I haven't seen the last season oh
oh I will I will oh
I like the boys
yeah the boys was fine I like the boys
fun great severance
I was a little slow for me I gotta give
another shot I hear it's amazing great
show Severance okay yeah yeah yeah I
like Adam Scott yeah right no that's a
show I got it I started it and I was
like I was drunk and I was like I need
to pay attention for this [__] yeah do
you guys like horror movies not really
but if it's a good one I'll watch it
well you know like horror movies there's
no development there's no character
what's give me a good Harmony
give me a good one I'm sure I liked it
hereditary that it was I gotta watch
great movies that was great great movie
right terrifying terrifying I'm gonna
watch it Tony Collette yeah what's the
name I worked with her before really
who directed that movie um his name is
um don't you tell me Jewish guy yeah you
already asked her yeah he's good he's so
good who has Tony Coletta is she cool
I've never met Tony he was that with a
girl I think so you worked with me
girl I worked hard with her yeah
how about this one have you seen this
one
Let the Right One In oh great movie well
then you like them well I like a good I
like a good idea that's all I'm asking
the good ones okay do you see X didn't
like it really I don't like sex Ah
that's it I've never heard that horror
movies with my sexuality in it oh they
all have sexuality what about all of it
90 but you have old titties in it too
right yeah I would have thought you
liked that because you do a podcast with
one no
which is you know it's working out it's
working it's good yeah it's I had a
great time yeah that's a horror movie I
don't know how you do that [__] yeah
that's terrifying whatever but there's
real love there though you know you do
love her I I I'm in love with her dude
not in love but I I love her like
and I don't know why people don't
[__] understand this no well maybe
well maybe it'll do it can I just say
something
[Laughter]
so what I'm saying is is that I you know
when you share a life with somebody for
10 years and also you start a business
with them which is tigerbelly was a
business and uh you think so oh yeah
it wasn't I mean it's a very successful
business yeah no when I'm saying that I
don't think it's you know because I
don't view relationships as just of a
sexual you know I mean contract with
somebody same right it's a spiritual
contract with somebody it's an emotional
contract with somebody and you become
friends with that person and you care
about that person yeah so for me it's
like I can't understand why people think
that it's weird that I'm doing a podcast
still with somebody that I love
oh just going off of things she might
have done to you
no I think Bobby
what I would say is I think people doing
this is like you know I didn't know what
else to do right so it's like I had to
do that you know what I mean because
that's fighting words I'm sorry sorry
you need I think time like distance and
time to heal no no sometimes no no no
healing would it be healing dude from a
breakup
it deteriorated over years it wasn't an
Abrupt breakup like out of nowhere there
were things that were not working for
the last couple of years and it was sort
of like you know I mean we could kind of
see you know what I mean the end but my
point though is is like I got in a fight
with Comics that the comics are like
screaming match and were like you know
some of these [__] Comics were like
no once it's done it's done I don't even
ever talk we wouldn't know we don't work
there yeah yeah
a little [__] huh
my point though is is that because there
are a lot of people online that give her
a hard time no I would never they do
they [__] they [__] rip on her
online
I hate all the online ripping yeah these
nerds out there that's all they have
they're not this is their soap opera
yeah and it it's like you know do say
whatever you can have your opinion but
I'm just telling you that it hurts me I
get it I hear that and it [__] hurts
me and and clearly you do love her and
and you want in your life and they
should accept that yeah I'll tell
another thing friend yeah Santino yeah
and I want to say this and I want to get
emotional but that dude right has stood
by me right doing thick and thin like a
war okay
I will never betray him
ever it's weird when people say that
like who is talking about betraying I
know I'm just telling you because this
is like games
and I'm gonna say this too right with
you two right now yeah sure never betray
you you won't betray us so we should
never really right I feel the same way
about you so what am I that's my point
that's why we have are you on we like it
we have no plans but we have people on
this podcast you don't like that much
well the bartender's right here
but my point is is that like for me
listen I want to say this too man this
is [__] real [__] right here dude
right
my manager I could be with a big fancy
colorful you know what I mean energetic
management company I could pick anyone I
want and they would sign me right but I
have the manager I have because this
woman in the 90s you know I mean pointed
at me goes I believe in you wow I'm
going and I am going to stick by you and
during my successful time I'm gonna
stick my hair I'm not with the CAA
because they're a big shiny [__]
agency they're pretty not Blake I know
they are but Matt Blake I was with when
he was at the smaller ones all right and
I traveled with him to see hey I just
happened to be there because my guy this
is a great speech yeah yeah hey my God
keep going that my guy my guy right so
I'm loyal yeah that's all I'm saying
yeah and I'm loyal to kalilah hell yeah
that doesn't work but yeah yeah go stick
with kalilah you got a relationship you
got a contract you got a friendship yeah
yeah hang out how do you do this you
gotta hold it oh does it burn no are you
buzzed right now yeah yeah
this is our second episode today we've
been drinking these monologues you do
they're good
they're so dramatic I think you need I
mean you say you don't watch Yellowstone
but this is very Yellowstone a man only
has his family and the man will stand by
his family hey you're right I guess you
know I just I guess you know I just you
know I feel things and I say it you know
I love that about you yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know I get emotional about it
but it's like you know this is a there's
going to be a war I'm going to be with
you there's me I love that there's no
work I know there's no work that's my
point by the way if there's a war in
here on our side we're losing this ain't
what do you mean well I can't fight with
Charlie
or like a knob yeah we hit in the trees
and we made tunnels I'm just saying if
we're on the same side of a war I don't
feel good about our odds yeah what are
we like none of us are Fighters the
Vietnam War how do I feel about it
[Laughter]
I think it's about time someone weighed
in on that you know you lost right well
America lost oh yeah we did yeah not
that I'm on the Vietnamese side I'm just
saying we lost a lot of lives yeah it
wasn't pretty but you guys did good with
the [__] Hiroshima that was good
um that was Oppenheimer in theaters [__]
yeah dude yeah thanks for Nolan yeah
that looks good it looks great I mean
Oppenheimer too Hiroshima dude
I'm on screen for five seconds but I do
a real dramatic whoa you know what I
mean when the bomb hits am I [__] my
Nuclear Shadow dude well you know it's
so good I do like a nuclear shot like
this and it goes under the [__]
sidewalk
dude imagine your nuclear Shadows like
if there was a [__] bomb that hit New
York right now what would you do oh it'd
be podcasting it'd be sad you would be
but I mean we've been talking about
stamps.com
I went to Pompeii you bring the Pompeii
was it nice no it's not nice but it's
still preserved and Ash because they got
lava all over and this guy's jerking off
seriously there's a dog like you know
there's a lady like they have a
whorehouse where the guy's in bed
waiting to get laid it's crazy the
jerking off guy that's got to be rough
if that's like your family member you're
like that was your dad yeah yeah no but
so they were petrified in Ash in Ash and
that's how fast the volcanic yeah it was
it dumped on them like this like a rain
oh is that right yeah all the uh Palmas
whatever it's called flew up in the air
and came down to smoke like this
oh my God and it's still there after all
these hundreds you can walk around and
see a human being jerking off he's doing
this
wow like a black just a human shape like
a silhouette and when he goes to heaven
that's probably the [__] body tester
he does right imagine and then you're in
heaven ah Jesus
is that my back yeah yeah right whatever
you're doing yeah oh [__] that's real
yeah see he was contemplating where the
69 was
well that looks like he was doing the
candy challenge
yeah it's a hell of a place apparently
in the movie he says he really wants you
to feel the nuke and I'm like I don't
know what the [__] that means but like
if you see that IMAX that I bet that's
some scary [__] wait what are you
talking this Nolan oh Nolan no one said
no yeah he wants to feel very like oh so
there is they show the nuke in the thing
oh wow damn so I can't be an Oppenheimer
too
I [__] missed the casting on that
yeah the new kids and they're just
Americans dancing
tips I've auditioned for 9 000 things
never got one you get all all these gigs
uh acting wise so does Santino give me
give me a tip wait do you still audition
now
[Music]
I'm back man who farts in the new
Tarantino movie yeah yeah yes all right
I think this is what's gonna happen for
you dude all right it's just gonna
happen
what the hell is that mean when is it
gonna get some what I'm saying is it
it's like don't think about it it's just
gonna it's gonna come around okay right
because that's what has happened to me I
there's years where I don't get an
acting job and all of a sudden out of
nowhere I'll just get a call right you
just gotta throw it out that you want to
do it on your podcast you want to be an
actor right yes well then don't do that
okay voice over what I like your voice
though like a Bob's Burger a Simpsons a
Family Guy something like that would be
ideal or do what you know what Bill Burr
does no he made his own thing like a
month ago Bill calls me and he goes I'm
doing a short
and I go he goes I want you in it so the
next week I'm in makeup and I'm doing a
short with them you know man and he he
spent hundreds of thousand dollars on
the shore wow and he's got cranes and
special effects and the cat was so
impressed it was like a movie set yeah
and it builds birds were acting and give
me notes and this and that and it's like
in my mind I'm like oh you can just you
know make [__] yeah yeah you could write
[__] and make [__] and put it out there
that's the move because the industry's
so slow and I think we're moving faster
than them podcasts YouTube specials
We're not gonna wait they're trying to
figure out
how to get here exactly they're trying
to get a piece of this oh yeah right
because we kind of
come on dude like the kind of comment do
we do they can't put that [__] on TV
yeah it's all off the boat or whatever
the [__] or or uh Mike and Molly yeah
but Eastbound and Down was a huge hit
but I haven't seen that on that's you
know you know that's HBO right and um
yeah it's different that's a little
different but it's not they're also
they're a little anomal they're
anomalies you know what I mean but at
the but Network TV some of these
screaming streaming things it's all
Cookie Cutter comedy and that's not the
world that I want to live in no well
that's why podcast is so popular yeah so
we're we're kind of taking up a section
in people's minds you know what I mean
oh yeah and people will listen to us and
don't even watch TV they don't even know
what's out there right I mean at work
they can listen to it this is a great
thing you know I mean and you know I
only watch TV like cable when I'm in a
hotel and it's just so much [__] to sift
through and then if you do find
something decent is 8 000 commercials
and you're like oh I'll just go back to
YouTube there were people like the
commercials so they don't have to invest
I guess it's it's you're not investing
in the show it's like it's an office
rerun you're like I'll fold [__] while I
do this yeah right right oh so I saw a
document I don't want to tutor all the
horns and maybe I have to cut this out
but I do I want to do it a little bit
you've been tweeting all [__]
podcasts you piece of [__] finally had a
loud one you know in a weird way and
this is gonna sound gross we might have
to cut this out but um
you know I saw a documentary called me
meet me in the bathroom it was a book
first you know that book no it's about
The Strokes it's about the New York in
the 2000s yeah music scene yeah with the
yaya Strokes Interpol and um you know
these bands TV on the radio LCD
Soundsystem sure and there was just in
that time period in New York
in the 2000s that's where you wanted to
be when you were you know I mean if you
liked cool music it was a scene and I
feel like the same kind of things are
happening with podcasting I really do I
think 10 years from now 15 years from
now somebody might do a documentary
about the whole thing that's how I think
it is what we're doing and I mean I
don't want to say you know I'm saying it
out loud is weird and now you can see
that there are P podcasts out there one
of their names that are again like we're
what they talk about yes and they want
to bring us down right right and when
you see that happening there's something
going on here here great Point that's a
great point I completely agree we gotta
be done man all right yeah how long is
this
this comes out July 4th is our special
July 4th right is that so is there any
stuff yeah where are you yeah you want a
plug what are you gonna do you got not
bad friends nothing you done I'm done
you're quitting the business yeah
what do you guys got all right a lot of
[__] guys
hey bring it in
it's over the violin
[Music]
wow it's beautiful uh what do I got
um
uh scroll down [__] uh I don't
know Northampton Burlington I can't see
should Albany
Bethlehem York Chicago should be on sale
in New York next week announcement
special New York announcement
theater and MSG can't really say it yet
but I'm playing
my socials next week Cleveland Columbus
Pittsburgh you see all this horseshit
you get it
there we go Bobby's in the fall in the
fall me and Andrew are doing uh Denver
we're doing uh Minnesota Wisconsin DC so
we're gonna do a fall tour me and Andrew
hell yeah
and friends they should have played that
violin when he was talking his sad
intervention story all right uh Taft
theater uh I'll be in Louisville San
Diego at the Balboa
uh I can't read that a bunch of theaters
Springfield Missouri uh Hershey PA
D.C Oklahoma City Dallas Portland
Providence Cleveland Grand Rapids Denver
uh Grand Junction marknormancomedy.com
check out the website get some Bodega
cat I forgot Toronto too samrail.com
he's good killing it brother beard you
vision is the same place gooder would
say less and I'm finishing up the we
might be drunk uh recipe book soon so
we're gonna try to put that out soon I
got the recipes ready we're gonna take
photos soon and then we'll get it out
for it you put the paper plane on the
map and listen to Bad friends
I love thanks Gotham Studios happy
birthday America Sally thanks for coming
in and we'll see you all at held comedy
[Music]
and I get down in the same way
dangerous
[Music]
I'm out to lunch here in New Orleans
this woman doesn't look like I remember
her and I get down in the same way
[Music]
true